Sandras ganzes Haus mit Erde einbauen
und sagen da waren Erdrutsch
was machst du eigentlich gerade bei
deinem Pferdestall guck mal Luca ich
hatte ja diese ich ich sehe es auch
es sei hässlich aus das habe ich mir
eine doppelhecke gemacht sieht irgendwie
schöner aus boah Luca ich rieche meine
Mutter hat was Affen geiles gekocht nur
wenige Minuten später zu meinem Haus was
ist mit
[Musik]
Luca
nein
bei Sandra war
komplett jetzt jetzt zwei
[Musik]
aus als vorher bin ich ganz ehrlich Mann
sorry
[Musik]
danach kann man ein Haus wir reden weißt
du was ich gemacht habe ich habe hier
Erde hingesetzt ich dachte mir ey ist
lustig ich habe nichts kaputt gemacht du
baust mein Baumhaus ab und tötest meine
Katze Sachen wieder aufzubauen ist die
eine Sache aber etwas zu töten geht gar
nicht und siehst du das was hier oben
jetzt befestigt ist
[Musik]
was ist das
was Rotes TNT
[Musik]
mein Haus
mein Haus guckt euch mein Haus an
das tut mir leid ich baue es auch wieder
auf ich wusste nicht dass ein TNT so
viel Schaden macht aber
um ganz ehrlich zu sein mein Spaß hier
mit der Erde das macht nichts kaputt ich
habe das einfach nur dran gesetzt
genauso wie wenn ich dir Spinnennetze
reingelegt habe das hat nie was kaputt
gemacht das ist nämlich wichtig weil ich
möchte nicht unsere Welt zerstören wer
hat denn jetzt gerade die Welt von mir
zerstört
ja
tötet
ja aber zu Recht wir bauen dein Haus
wieder auf ich helfe dir auch ich mache
alles wieder so wie vorher
obdachlos an den Strand habe ich jetzt
überlegt
ja ich bin jetzt ein Penner Digger
passiert
[Musik]
ja sieht gut aus danke
gesehen habe
wie schnell ist der der slenderman
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf geht in der
Höhle gehen in die Höhle
Mama gehen in die Höhle schnell
ich versuche zu töten
okay er ist tot gruselige Geräusche er
ist tot
Macarena
er kam auf einmal vorne hinten Digger
das sieht schon sehr sehr geil aus komm
mal hoch warte mit dem Blumen von hier
aus meinem Dings
[Musik]
schön
hier hochgekommen
bei Minecraft ja
aber wir beiden nicht das haben wir nun
Real Life vor
[Musik]
wirklich du bist der größte immer mit
der Ruhe okay
[Musik]
Leute ich bin total gerade auf 100
Moment
vor ich lebe nicht mehr solche Momente
tut mir leid dass ich das geschrieben
habe mit dem Haus sein wollen damit hat
das alles angefangen das stimmt du wirst
auch blockiert gleich okay
ja du musst deine Kamera Szene musst du
da halt reinziehen
aber dicker die ist auf einmal weg ein
paar Sekunden später
[Musik]
unten was gesagt Deutschland
in unserem Doppelbett
[Musik]
ist das noch da
oh Laser
do you want to talk to me selfie
wir testen das jetzt mal mit dem Riesen
Zombie hier also dem prank den nichts
anderes spielen möchte ich gebe jetzt
jemand den Befehl ein
das hier ist das
warte doch letztes Mal oder leute seht
ihr hier irgendwo Eisen
oh mein Gott
[Musik]
und er brennt nicht mal oh mein Gott
das sind so krass
was ist denn von meinem Haus
[Musik]
so schön was hast du gemacht
so schön
oh mein Gott und er ist auch noch
lebendiglich
ich mache mir in die Hosen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du das gemacht
von meinem zu Hause
[Gelächter]
aber wieder wir müssen nur einmal aus
dem Bild laufen wenn wir einmal zu
meinem Portalen laufen dann müssten
eigentlich weg sein
tut mir leid aber mein Internet kackt
funktioniert nicht ja okay alles gut ach
Freunde das war doch mal wieder ein
interessanter Stream ist einiges
passiert
[Musik]